we're live hello
your favorite ladies right here hello
holy doofus hello darkness my old friend
she likes my jug you doofus do you want
to play up that's pretty good and I
can't speak come on guys we want to play
games I lost to a cheater challenge as
challenge the st. Louis chess club
ladies I'm popular now yes there are
very popular doofus all right let's find
this person how limited wait it can't be
casual okay so it has to have a time
limit like 5 minutes or less hello Tom
Tom Sawyer
oh we have a famous person in the chat
hockey pivoted ah he's from Turkey hello
why are you in yeah good morning we got
one good evening good afternoon good
night whatever you are yes that's rated
so that's good we can play them yeah
both of those are fine yeah go at this
one friends yeah yeah we can start with
that not too soon please I'm bill still
waiting let's do want to go crazy or do
you want to go not too crazy not too
crazy alright not too crazy
oh oh yeah the chat hi girls from Miami
hello those sad week
oh cool does anybody want to give me any
comments hey
okay you are the strongest plans yeah
with his challenge sleep now July the
stronger no it has to be a five minute
or less and it can have no increment or
go on in st. Louis it's currently 8:30
oh okay fun headphone users ready for a
boring old open I mean game possibly
okay yeah I keep saying that's like I
mean av tell you he or she held an opto
probably he I'm gonna go with a he yeah
I look you're not here I apologize so so
how come you did night see so I wanted I
just want to bring my pieces out and I
[Music]
really don't want to trap my Bishop here
so I have this weird idea like wait if I
say it's well you know it yeah don't say
so how are you guys long time no see
yeah we haven't streamed into a while
yeah rated wait why related my said our
accounts
hi Rosen hello Eric did you win your
tennis match oh you play tennis or was
it casual
not rated I'm rated tennis match oh my
god
[Music]
Griffin said that he learned the London
from
okay maybe brings this bring these bad
boys back to Texas sounds like a plan
didn't go here can't go here yeah five
minutes or less it's wrong so we can do
3-0 increment or three occupied with
Niner so I'm gonna open up some room
hello Leonardo how are you Sammy minutes
five plus zero is okay oh you lost
[Music]
perhaps use or no choice at all encoded
you yeah why not
Wow oh look I forgot about b3 no I
should have put D forever okay okay why
not less proven otherwise
[Music]
those are really pretty emojis from who
from Roman lightning Oh
maybe those aalayam signifies me I guess
my today Check Writer oh that's a nice
huh
what time shall I like the square for
the night I'm glad you do what is the
meaning of those modules it's a flower
what's this emoji with the hands up is
that like I'm giving you a hug
oh no it's hi thank you oh yeah that's a
beautiful my voice age while I sound
weird no you don't I do I can hear
myself even if I couldn't I mean can't
you hear it all the time yeah but I
actually recorded my voice too just for
the purpose of listening to it to see
how horrifying it isn't pretty
horrifying I feel that way about my
voice too no no no I'm sick I mean I was
sick last week even when I'm not I feel
that way about my voice Oh Abby wants us
to play her
okay Abby you have to challenge us booth
and it has to be like five minutes or
less but we're in the middle of playing
someone right now so you gotta wait oh
thank you thank you
you should deploy be 500 push for c6 and
stuff I think I might be wrong though
about doesn't make any sense
what does somebody in this comment
section just said which Apple that's
what I say all the time it's why you do
move come on do something no not you
tech writer talking about something else
you know
with what that's the question yeah come
to mama
there's a high chance I'm wondering so
let me know if I am oh yeah oh yeah I'm
wondering no oh yeah it's good oh yeah
what about bishop why maybe wait where
did you go back then back there got to
get my Knights here why do you check use
me check we will check with what Oh
Danny Danny Danny Danny okay you're
attacking this I don't want you to touch
my bishop get away better space
guess my next move
[Music]
almost come here come here come come you
have a seat I have a sleep for you comes
Johnny Danny maybe if we just do that
does that work
sign in touch oh you guys are trying to
try it back with them yes I think the
matter went too far
ring-ring group
cleaned up or clean you're on our
official accounts careful reach reach
JC come on
I thought you're supposed to tell me
when I'm wondering stuff oh yeah the
bishop check I thought I was have some
sound check here yeah first maybe done
that but is there anything you guys yeah
can you hear us who are talking javi
says Oh Abby says you fix the audio okay
it's a guy I don't like what I'm doing
but I'm gonna do it is the face cam okay
dude over your heads up I told you I
don't like what I'm doing so it's okay
there's no cultures yeah
away
shoot
my mind oh yeah your last marriage list
this game lasted longer than my last
marriage who are you married to I'm
sorry
sounds like fun anything Las Vegas -
sounds like it I don't know what I'm
doing so I know I'm wondering a bunch of
stuff most likely where are you going my
friend hmm can you present your name
sure don't ask me questions
yeah Tracy likes my jokes okay hi yeah
I'm glad you do it's not like I could do
any better for you right now baby
Gigi adios okay who's next
did you know who they are six other Oh
challengers
okay I'm gonna choose oh holy doofus Oh
Abbi is the one that spy ran by which
Abbie Abbie upstairs oh I'll be happy
yeah you're gonna play some other people
Alison will play Holi doofus the next
one won't go Abby first hey does any of
you girls on pH know why my always black
okay now we can do the I don't don't
care then you're going to tell me what
to do Abby where are you Abby Abby I
thought I know
hello no no and now we do D at least
like a g6
I like t5 I won two games today
well sorry not if no offensive caro-kann
but look if you are going to play these
big space e5 okay the problem is I don't
play this with black or white and go I'm
actually sheet somewhere anything coming
oh no yeah really
that's all right back Aipom
I don't even know if they can hear me
sorry boys or they can only hear me this
is a disaster
ah Abby I'm not I'm being held against
my will you were first I was true story
I supported everything
oh my god I told something else you
taught the rights I told your initial
ideas correct all right my groups
I couldn't Bishop b5 would lose the
Queen yeah so officially down appease
people thank you
this was CARICOM started the first move
that's the whole thing it's not like I
know the rest
yeah you have to dismiss or you'll get
caught mm-hmm glad seeing somebody named
thoughts later I do
and
Wow but tea that's rude yeah
excuse me what is to say what is just
saying oh my god
does any don't have the brains to play
chess excuse you you saw so many ways
where is it he's from my country and
like he's despising the girls you gotta
watch my TED talk before Utah come on we
are living in the in the 21st century
get over it
if you can go to female doctors we have
exact same brain as you do the problem
with female doctors then you have to
check yourself in a mental hospital mend
you to put the link of my TED talk and
tell him to watch that before he breeds
the next breathe breath or something
like that but I might be too strong on
this topic so Abby I mean I like the
fact that people are making
generalizations based on us they're
blaming all Geary's because he has a
brain of his own he can talk and tank
for himself that's that's weak that's
very sweet but I think he has a brain
okay hey my doc I this man named thought
says
again are you a doctor or nurse Sciences
because I'm a scientist we haven't had a
scientist in the chest they dissected
human brain oh my god can I just enough
to know that it's different
oh yeah they saw it with their own bare
eyes is it safe to say that this person
really pissed me off
no that's not this person bet on
something you love you why don't you
join us who are we talking about wine
come be on ladies night yeah she needs
to be here ah I like that wise person
who said thrilling stuff yeah thank you
whoever you are I mean I can't really
read the chat so you watch Beauty fight
we really need to be able to ban people
every moment that is a new species
guys seriously planet tech murder -
yelling cover my Hawk everybody
I'm serious fine listen some education
inserted to every mom in there bad what
can I do respect women okay Google ramen
what did I do
what is ramen for a good cry replying
that no I want her to put the link
because so that's somebody asked about
it do any of you have it tdawg i we
don't I don't have that we do this is a
lot of argue don't worry about this I am
because in society that I have
unfortunate lis pendens like
to deal with okay thoughts later
I really hate saying that but I would
say something we know they don't think
the same man you don't just because
they're different doesn't mean that
males are smarter as well thank you wash
my tongue the males are okay but just
yes there's video grandma amazing stuff
so hold on because they're rings hockey
Abbi okay
what you're doing I see what you're
going for just just is not like it's not
it right yeah
keep my tank safe I'm still owe my god
why can't I remember
although who cares
we are citizen of the planet so it's
okay Abby what are you doing sorry
you're supposed to be up there playing
me alright I'm please please you got so
comfy too then you go oh you have no
idea
this [ __ ] should know someone else is
playing someone is playing on their
account they just have you somebody made
a malaria running out of time you're
cheating
you two laughing do you have a grudge
oh my god oh we are playing against it I
should've known okay I'm running out of
time yeah we can't play like what wow
that's not cool
I wonder which Grandmaster were playing
right now yeah boring way like scuse me
but I really like this person is really
boring
we are no the comments they're saying in
the comments my coins okay okay thank
you yeah thank you Stanford it's really
okay who are we doing ramen because
we've got the whole need to play another
person yeah well they only do that okay
wait don't grab masters like presenting
as a bezoar yeah that's like that
actually not cool actually that's really
not a little not cool it's okay
I want to know which grandmas are we're
playing okay
my openings my mouse my openings I said
okay new rule that's no kind of allahö
no it's no French no freedom of choice
super Thank You Evie who was playing for
you're actually seriously who was who
was it you were here physically and then
someone else
we're not playing holy doofus nice name
oh that must be Apple yeah sorry
English hope you are fine with the joke
I think we're not I think he's here he
must heed the one who plays against us
you should apologize from dorsa yes he
suffered the opening choice no you know
I don't know what that is that's my my
gambit includes King sacrifice no I
don't recommend to anyone
I have no idea what that is oh that's
his calling you
[Laughter]
Thank You Chuck Melissa stuck monk I
don't been allowed to play Kings gambit
not sure um we don't the Kings gambit
because you know we can't who plays the
stuff but I Romans and I should play
damn it I mean a lot of people call
sexist yes I really really want to
yeah I have to sighs you to myself a lot
on this stream and it takes so much
strength
oh please Rox gambit
excuse you what is your taking yard who
do you think I guess spawn gambit how
about no yes you sack the game for it
perfect next time it's really
unfortunate ladies we already played if
I adopt you will you send me whose thing
if you the doctor no no no if we adopt
you we will send you an air kiss yeah
I'm not going to kiss anyone especially
because I lost their little gambit is
too complex the route candid oh really
yeah they are very intricate so that's
why you don't play it
why I feel like I'm really cool to sing
not because the movement are not free to
play games they are doing many other
things they're not even to one in South
undress so your information is wrong
yeah only I found it she's not playing
at a plaintiff but she we are do multi
daddy we are doing chest getting talking
she's being awesome in Oxford University
yes that's why the gambit is only played
by me not even Magnus and using
certified trademark trademark doctors
donated Lee hopefully let's see clear
okay
trademark clear you have to learn how
play the King's gambit because people
play that gambit against you will okay
open us okay we have opening you take me
in magnitude it is how sweet alright
who's the next paper guys very
invigorating that person who wanted to
play there nobody mean he's gone my he
stood needless he got embarrassed but
let's play whoever is the highest rated
chess nickel Oh kids good not try to
play the highest good good not good it
is true that's it wait yes anus you had
the bar got the same troll can cause
don't don't think all sexes then move on
of my life can you
I really wanted to yeah I'm finally
whites yay that's why you belong to
Barry black resigns okay so I'm going to
play what I don't like the gambit either
okay I don't know menace against players
who actually know what they're dreaming
about person mg but this is for the
purpose of my students I have no idea
what is empty to doubleu faith should
have faced one of them well he chickened
out look why don't you come flesh on her
ass got too scared he like yeah I'm
solid guys even miss solid 999 out there
anything no they think it's too low
that's why they say solid because yeah
you know yeah yeah the world rigs a
two-for-one ah
wait is this this person who's that
person ladies to displace chest wait
what freezer please Jessica can you say
hi in the chip I don't say testicles can
you see woman like I'm not really
talking at all okay
I say Jessica Lambeth we are looking for
you can you say hi nice job everything
for example I don't cook well
good anything you don't you can't just
everyone has to be good at everything
example I don't I don't want cook well
either okay
Kenyon can you stop specifying roles for
specific genders anyone anyone on this
planet can do anything they want
Jane you just may be speaking come on
you know that bishop on c1 is going to
become so handy yeah Tracy hated it
Tracy's kids because she couldn't stop
she couldn't stand the position from
black side
it's a PHA this party it's party it's
fatty damaged my name is Ellie Bracken
Toshi
Wow the kingdom looks sloppy I mean I'm
sorry we all I'm sorry
quantum flower that's sorry for the gum
named after mr. gambit quack mr. Ciampa
touch you know you have a child and you
you named a child laughter again mr.
gambit yeah you can name your child
mr. gambit Oh Oh No eat it I don't know
how to spell no copyright you can't sing
on YouTube anymore ya might wanna work
on that if you want to seem smart yes
what what are we going to work on good
guy oh yeah yeah see he doesn't know
English
put him out I'm sorry who is this five
minutes no increment yes it is this
specific game is five minutes with a
challenge and you named it after me so
what how you should get creating more
than a name and gambit after you yeah
can you show me the falling testicle can
you give us some time no no they can
give you the time I
look I don't know excuse me that was a
quickly spelling of quark
Thank You Jessica
we need more time can you give space for
that creep you would yeah I told you
what is your username dude wow I didn't
take yeah I took I took French but I
forgot five years what did you use it
what is that username save Louis chess
club st. Louis Tesla do
that's are you know I think that means
law my qualities track should no no I'm
getting lost maybe like future
but it's not pasta if you want to play
me my name you need to challenge as we
can't see your challenge in the list you
have to bow down and challenges that's
how it works yeah we don't have your
challenge so you need to challenge us
first so first please party party ok
party challenges cool right terrific
Tracy Tracy Tracy Tracy upon popular
demand
chance you need to challenge st. Louis
Chess Club
tell them to look right yeah it's on the
screen
guys please the come on this way come on
Jessie cool give them more time yeah
thank the Queen
please I guess he was talking into just
three paths just suis perdu I am lost
and time oh yeah I'm sorry it's okay
hahaha
he 3 goes to between
we've been cute what's that oui oui oui
oui baguette yes yes oui oui
the king is really predicted at the end
of the day no have to because yeah
that's time lost in searching history
here today no one of you playing other
than daughter she's she's the strongest
baby no baby no children
she's the strongest she's an
international master you guys that what
excuse you look at me hanging pieces
left and right it's okay if you think
you are entitled to hang them oh my head
is killing me
sorry I have a headache oh we might have
something I think this might be the time
to call the police because there will be
a murder for sure I have to me we would
like to report a murder
Oh Tracy
oh she's Stewie 75 oh okay is this
another trap nice do you have another GM
with you yeah I'm Tracy you should be
here five minutes okay put me up against
anyone but her and then I might not get
mated in 15 what oh oh yeah the chin
yeah it's okay it's okay
oh my I have a headache yeah sighing
sighs oh I know I know I know this I
know
if somebody else is playing for her
whoever you are you will owe me a hops
but it stays if not the actual player
did you hear me Tracy
did you hear that Tracy if it's not you
or if even for one move somebody else
play it's like I want my hot chocolates
take it big
this is this opening is scotch scotch
and d'Orsay is playing in honor
okay holy [ __ ] excuse you who do you
think we are
I mean we might be bad oh yeah you
should play a four against the immortal
[Music]
pawn to a4 meet a four black resigns
[Laughter]
yeah I have I have been storing some
jokes now gladly is mating one meat eat
one mate in one
okay mate oh I love it
yeah especially when someone else is
late for us
that's support that's a fourth tragic
ink trade you know I'm the master of
Kings sacrifice I don't have to trade
it's my title given by the very
prestigious organization called Nicky
[Laughter]
he's a friend Tracy Tracy getting is
getting aggressive one more time
Wow that's not even I did the same thing
today
Tracy's having a flashback Tracy same
thing today yeah I'm liking the top
three in my school but there's only like
four other decent chess players that are
kind of good so um I go to the Internet
and get my butt kicked
do you want me to sympathize with you
while I meet you
happy first you know Tracy is going to
give you how I don't know somebody
something awesome and happy okay wait
okay abeyance Tracy our names each other
I guess I might mean he's like among
four players I'm one of the best fun now
I thought I should go to engineering
find someone so I came here so that I
can survival made because I didn't
really do not win yeah I'm really sorry
you're not going to win take point on
this
that's me
excuse me it seems like you haven't met
me yes absolutely
I'm a chess GM grating is 9000 9000 my
rating cannot be computed leaving Magnus
beggining oh yeah hello Jimmy art of the
fence
tech rider hang in there hang in there
the undead can be displayed by not black
Abby's playing now it's not tree CP you
are tricking us today neck collars
bughouse wrong that's not under
nah I'm just keep on this it's like
crazy chest hair when I'm really like mm
okay that's good
[Music]
what time control challenge evaluates
anything below 5 5 5 3 i can play blood
but I can't promise I can't promise it's
fun I mean Bullock is fun so so much fun
I mean but I just do like oh here you
are my rating every time I play Willis
[Laughter]
we got confused - a four and oh ok I see
I see an A be explained from state
Tracy's account we deserve it we need a
hot chocolate
we need a hot chocolate not just dorsa
we need that - yes I got the whole
picture whole picture HD full HD 42
megabytes or whatever it is pic
megapixels of how do in fastest even if
you lose it bullet it just doesn't hurt
than normal chest so much give it up
give it up hey for know and it's so fast
like ok you play to a4
to e75 got it oh you got it got it happy
that's from every wake up for this will
hurt this hurts this hurts
[Music]
hello darkness my old friend hello hello
you're dead I don't know why you say
goodbye I say hello
oh all rights to play beside me Mickey
because I mean your income why I'm
streaming on twitch oh yeah we have to
go cheaters Ian this will be the last
game the tactics quatuor this some nice
racing my dreams e na ha did you get
flashbacks oh yeah
fork city scotch I like it I like this
[Music]
LM is legendary monster Dean Morgan oh
[Music]
you stay for 1 million you missed a
significant tactic norsu a four we can't
speak Arabic no wait can you speak
Arabic we cannot speak Arabic
we can't even say a word I feel like I
can thank you say a word in Arabic I I
can figure little Russian like colossal
oh I know baby
Yankee cavalry what is your game why is
the Toyota Queen yeah years I didn't
know that now you call it fierce listed
yeah that's called all the pieces would
can you get it girls play chase chess960
want to play it feels like I'm not gonna
get the time maybe next time yeah we can
do chess variants next time it would be
fun sixteen it's so messed up I mean TV
on a blue I love you know I think this
dreams ladies playing people night like
their piece I mean playing chess with
people what is this dream what is this
dream where are we
holly los monos I it's C from Turkey
yes yeah I have a leaky knee i it must
be so early in Turkey
hello my revoir can you just stop going
easy and play the night yeah bed can you
please
my who is fun hi hi Danish I've heard
about that I've heard about that
sacrificing t5 yep is that alia or
Danish yeah we're good why horses
playing do it do it do it do we
sacrifice or not so yes or no yes I
don't see that line do it but I can see
that line and it's going to be very cool
I feel like so my followers on Twitch
told me that there was a thing called
suspended scholars wait I don't know
what that is you know please let me know
what is that what happened to door sauce
boys we have two microphones and she
gave it to me oh yeah she's also sick so
this guy first comes and tells us that
like almost very insightful comments
about women brains and off no no no no
no it's not the same person girls let's
single by any chance so it's all yeah
excuse me we are not available
I said it's probably it so Carson that's
really interesting
I mean I'm Mike muscala second layer
saying I think flavourless more toll
than real I'm interested in the ground
master she's cute Hey oh those hot
secret admirers I mean we we don't know
their name
oh yeah baby know their name you know do
you remember did you watch the video
about a tennis player someone proposes
during a match and then she says how
much money do you have
let's go with that how much money do you
have
[Laughter]
excuse me we we are a family-friendly
Channel okay it's rate Dennis I don't
know which we insert or insert their
checking account
yeah sure
I see you I mean we can show that don't
be silly
there's something wrong yeah maybe the
keyword google it
yeah she's famous you know if you if you
haven't watched her cat secret at all
got a tech writer cuz they've been here
since the beginning destroy
hey cried a bye-bye see you later and
find those type of humor
yes chess overhears excuse me my tiger
did you i'll only washed your dead dog
since no sir
yeah alright door so this is probably
gonna be our last game cuz it's two
minutes till nine Wow is it possible to
come to visit Egypt if you play for a
little hot chocolate
I don't like to kill my cats play chess
better than I do
okay yes we are as you can tell amazing
attacking position we didn't yeah oh yes
that's a good move I wait who's the pot
well it's the best one yes you won the
game no not yet but it's a cause it's
free yeah just just like let's just take
me
sweeping sweeping pieces Indiana there
in st. Louisan Indiana or yeah google it
google it hey somebody said if you play
a four I'll donate okay how are we so
sure about that but maybe we should do
it so yeah okay I'm going to donate how
much money are we talking about we will
play a far as soon as you donate yes
yeah
Gigi hey now wait for reason yeah
Gigi yeah are you
come on Slayer how much money are you
are we talking about yeah I mean we're
not going to do it for $1 cents
[Laughter]
[Music]
alright yeah thank you so much for
watching yeah thank you
we will be here next Thursday today so
come back next Thursday because I'm not
here okay - yeah I'm not here next
Thursday I'll be in twitch both yeah but
let me go talk to Danny cuz he might not
realize that he needs to history nice
game thank you hola a bientot
thank you bye
[Music]